welcome to the stream i'm grandmaster
michael pearly grass
and um today we're going to talk about
um
whether or not to simplify into a pawn
and game um
this is uh this is important because um
ideally uh we should be able to
calculate until the end
uh the pawning and game although it is
known that
opponent games are
[Music]
sometimes quite difficult
but um if um
well in the endings also
we don't have so much time left so um
precise calculation is uh is required
uh nevertheless so
if possible we we need to try to
to assess the situation
[Music]
and decide whether to whether to go for
the ending or not
hello there how are you doing so
the first example for today is um is a
game
between van velli and weitasek
[Music]
white is to move here white is upon
up and also black's king is a bit
far away from the from the game
the king would really love to be on d6
but he's not
and white needs to take a decision here
should he go for the pawn ending or
simply continue
the game with the pawn up in the queen
and game
so
what uh what did this suggest here
[Music]
take the coin on g4 or play something
else
if white takes on g4 he has to make sure
that the ending is one
whereas if he doesn't take on g4 then
[Music]
he can just he can just play on
[Music]
and hope to win this descending because
he's a pawn up
so yeah uh
and wait a little bit for you to
to come up with some solutions to this
question
one with queen g4
okay i'll wait a bit more for for people
to think
and then
and then i'll discuss this this ending
it is quite it is quite complicated so
i want to give
so i want to give you a chance to
[Music]
to suggest moves
even now one viewer said you should take
one g4 because it's winning and then oh
no it's not winning so
you see if i let you a bit more then
who knows what you're going to suggest
so you're saying either to take on g4 or
play f3
okay
all right interesting
so well in this position it turns out
that
white has a large advantage
and
there are many there are many ways to
win
[Music]
i should say that quite a good way to
win this
this one is to go queen e6 for example
and then queen takes
pawn takes k7 just
this pawn ending is is one for sure
and should black go
the the pawn on f6 is under attack
should black go queen f3
then after king g1 white has two idea to
just push this
d6 with queen e7 and
it's winning but
uh precision is required so how about
queen takes g4
let's see what happens in this uh
because this is today's theme so let's
see what happens here so
pawn takes g4 king g2
k7
and now how do we continue with white
um d6 you mean well d6 you just give up
the pawn
so well obviously white
needs to go f3 in order to to bring the
king
into play as soon as possible so
let's see what could
happen here
pawn takes f3
then just the king takes
king d6 king e4 is completely winning
for white
so let's go back should black go
f5 then again
pawn takes pawn takes bring the king
well not much to not much to comment
here
because it's very straightforward
and once white takes the g4 pawn the
position is completely winning
so the best try is
king d6
while white has to take take on g4
what else king
king f3 k5 and
my question to you is how do you assess
this ending
why it is the move
what do you think about this
yeah obviously
king is three perhaps
but is it a win or a draw well
white is upon up but it's a double pawn
so
we need to we need to make sure
kg2 kg2 seems very
very strange and backwards backward move
now actually
this link is winning for white after
king is free
um well obviously f5 there is g5 and
it's
immediately winning and if king is 6
then king f4 king of 7
king f5
kmg7 and now there is g5
means don't take but king takes and
this is easily winning
just to make my point here for example
g4 is a mistake but obviously king f6 is
immediately winning
so we can
we can conclude that queen g4 was
winning the
game however
maybe white was not so sure about
[Music]
the resulting ending and he played s3
as many of you suggested
well i will not say it's a
it's a bad move but queen g4 was an
immediate win
so black goes queen g5
however f3 s3 is awakening so now black
has some chances to
to play queen d2 check and uh
[Music]
it's already annoying before it was
completely winning now
it may still be winning but you see
black has some practical chances
and how would you continue now
what should while doing this position
queen district king
king h3
come on i want to see the winning move
i want somebody to write a winning move
i didn't see it so far
who is helping me win this position it
went
f4 very good that's what i was expecting
the winning move yes indeed
so queen is six
well 26 uh not so clear as before
because now
black has
has some contemplation so
um
maybe queen e6 i don't know it could be
something like h4
with gun to play so um
in the game white played king h3 which
was a mistake
but the good move was uh f4
very good um pushing the phone once more
but
uh shouting off black's
black's queen and now this is winning
queen g4 is perhaps the most critical
and now white can uh simply push the
pawn to d6
well yeah sometimes it happens but you
you guessed
grandmaster's mistake so it's not bad
not bad at all okay
uh king d7 what else um
and now again uh white can uh
hello there uh white can simplify to a
winning pawn ending by queen e7 check
king c6 it's uh it's essential that
for the moment black doesn't have any
check
and now there we go d7 yes very good now
d7
um the eighth queen is next one so
no other way to bury don't take it
in this ending this king ending is
completely winning after
king h3 well it's a bit tricky
maybe but not too much king h4
king f7 h5 king g7
and yeah this is winning
f4 k7
king g4 kg6
and how do we win this position by the
way
[Music]
composition
king h4 well white's last move was king
g4
so king h4 would just go back to it
yes king
why it has to go all the way around
backside of black king
yes so it has to go
like this and he can do it for example
king
king f4
king age five
here
well yeah maybe even king king f3 is a
good one
but let's say g4
uh maybe yeah maybe king king fc is more
because just king g5 then
g4
[Music]
it can get fallen king f4 is winning
king h6
king f4 king j7 k4 and uh
white is
white is waiting
but also
also g4 is winning here for example
and then k6 is the same line as before
we have the same position as before it's
winning and if
king h4 then even
[Music]
king h3 is a possibility but e1 g5
yeah but here okay there is this
tactical trick
and white is uh
[Music]
is waiting but i agree the other one was
uh was simpler
it was more more easy
here for example
and checkmate but
uh yeah the other one was was easier
instead maybe maybe g4 white has to
calculate but king f3 it's
it's easier okay so this was uh
f4 was winning however in the game white
played king h3
and now now after queen c1 the the win
was
was much more difficult and in the end
white did not even manage to
to win i will show you a few more moves
but just to see
so that you see the problems that the
white suddenly encountered
king h4 and now an important move
how is how is black defended here
quinju one
well in the game he played the
queen d1 with idea to go queen g4
f5 and now queen d2
queen d1 and it turns out
that because of this weak king
the win is probably not there anymore
or anyway very very difficult
many checks and
white decided to give up the pawn
and
[Music]
a draw was agreed a few moves later
so this is
going back to to this position
you see it is important to to seize the
opportunity once uh
once it's there so here queen quintet g4
was very strong but white uh
white missed it and then the win was
was more and more difficult so let's
move on to
to the next position a game between
grieschuk and kramnik
and here we are
this uh
this arrows from
berlin berlin world
and
it's a fight bishop versus knight
and uh here white
white played g4 and white
of course black of course went to d4 and
now the pawn on b3 is hanging
well anyway even without g4 there was no
way to defend the
uh this report
okay and now my question is
what do you do as white here do you take
that knight on d4
or not 90 threatening take on this
so simplifying to the into the opponent
game or not
okay i will i'll let you think a little
bit about
the position
you need to you need to evaluate the
the pawn and the endgame that arises
afterwards
okay interesting interesting okay
i like you
a bit more
nope nope means don't take or what
no
okay interesting interesting so
the opinions are mixed some of you want
to get rid of that night
others
don't want to take the night just yet
well
let's see let's see what happened in the
game
[Music]
take take the knight also in the game he
took the knight
and now
blackwater do he took with the pawn
king e2 the king has to
has to come into play
king d7
[Music]
well now if c5 then there is a
also probably btx5 is winning but k6 is
he's just taking the e5 pawn so after
this
king d3 kinky five
uh
[Music]
king c4 and black has a
has a waiting move in reserve
f6 king d3
king d5 and guess what now the king is
going this
this way king c5
kn3
and this is lost so that's why in the
game
he goes uh king d3
instead of c5
black defense and now he has a protected
passport
uh king e4
king e6 well to give up the e5 pawn is
like
resigning so he he needs to
to try to to try and keep it so
the only way to do it is f4
and now
black just took obviously king takes
and yeah what
what do you play with black here
you have another interesting position
of course i'll give you some time to
think about it
so two people already saying d3
yeah f6
d3
f6 if you want to try to win no other
choice well in the game
black played d3 and gave up this uh
past protected pawn but after king is
three only move
then king e5 king d3
and you see king f4 and he's going after
the h3 pawn
um king e2 what else
kg3
king e3 king h3
king f4 king h4
[Music]
well now this is just a pawn up for
black in an ending
and it's it's winning after king f5 king
g3
white actually resigned one last trap
would be here for example
if white goes f6 then
after king f4 this this ending is a draw
but obviously there is no
there is no need for this so king is
just freaking f3 now
black has no position but obviously
black will not fall for this and black
goes
king g3 uh so
taking the knight was a mistake after
bishop takes d4 the position is
[Music]
is completely losing for for white
well probably he missed something
so actually it turns out that
after king is three
it is uh it is white who is pushing
and i um
the position okay i'll only show you a
few lines i don't want to
go into great detail
for this ending but i managed to find a
draw by black but
black has to be quite quite precise here
for example i think the best way for
black is to
take the bono b3 immediately
knight e6 seems to be losing
after king e4 k7
something like bishop c1 well there are
lots of analysis here so i don't want to
knight d4 bishop e3 knight b3
so it turns out that it's not so
uh it's not the end of the world for
white if he loses the beast report
because
he has the bishop versus knight and he
has a lot of targets you can see this
all the spawns on dark square that the
bishop can
can attack and here f4
you see h6 pawn becomes weak f6
and a position like this it turns out
it's
winning for white
[Music]
the idea is to bring
the bishop to g3 but yeah
it's it's a long line so i will i'll
just
leave it here
and uh yeah after king is three the only
way to
for black to save the game that i found
although i i didn't analyze it maybe so
much
um was to just take on uh
to just take on b3 and now
e6 is very strong with the idea to go
bishop g7 bishop h6
in bishop g5 uh
and then white pawn on the king side
would
would just decide again
[Music]
and uh
here black
black has to go king e7
very strong i mean taking on um
on e6 just loses to bishop g7
k7 here king f6 and now
f4 and these two pass pawns are going to
win
so k7 in order to to be in time to
play king f6
and
[Music]
yeah i think
c6 i think black is uh black is able to
make a draw here for example bishop g
bishop b5 then there is 95
and now a knight d4 sorry and white
black has the idea to take on f7 and
then play b5 and
simplify the position so probably this
uh
this should be a draw for example
[Music]
oh black f4 i'm
i'm not playing now i'm just uh it's
just a lesson
about an n games
we have f4
something like this after b5
um the position is
there are many exchanges and this ending
should
should be a draw
all right so going back to it here
it was quite an unfortunate mistake to
to simplify to our pawn ending because
it was lost
well after king is 3 white was
white was pushing perhaps the game was a
draw but still
black had to to be very precise
all right let's move on to the next one
and we have this position
yeah and here so black is going this way
we're going to see from black's point of
view because black is
the one taking the decision so just in
just a moment i'm going to
so white play bishop g7 here
um
asking about an exchange so now what do
we do
[Music]
do we take the bishop and simplify into
opponent and game later on it's a fourth
line
or you don't take that bishop
so once again black is going this way
white is going this way
and uh yeah i'm going to
to give you some time to
to think about this position
well did i
did i forget to say that uh
guys white has a threat white wants to
go rook h8
paint on pin the bishop
so rook h8 pinned the bishop and uh yeah
then then it's really winning for white
we we don't have to to ignore wise white
uh
threat
okay i'll leave you a bit more
to think about it
all right interesting interesting uh
solutions
i see that most of you don't want to
touch that
white bishop okay now some of you want
to take it
all right so let's see
okay since this is the days thing so
let's see what happens if
if black takes the bishop he took it
in the game so
bishop takes
then
pawn take well obviously he cannot take
on h7 because gh
queen so g3
and now the only chance for white is to
is to go for a pawn ending
king of seven and now
queen rook takes
rook takes king takes
yeah what do you think about this ending
so
black have to calculate this white is to
move
what do you think about this
okay interesting
you're very optimistic
it's good to be optimistic white is
winning draw
all right so white has to take one a5
king to f7
king to b6
well now if
the opinions are still shared about the
result of this
all right if king g6 then king c6
king f5 king d6 just loses because this
is the a6 pawn
and if king g5 then what
is black white going to move
what is white
playing
king d7 very good so not king d6 because
king of five and it is black who is
winning some king
d7 first king f5 king d6
and then black is to move uh he has to
give up the e6 pawn
and the ending is a win for white
so in the game here black played
king e7 but after king c7
uh he simply lost the e6 pawn
and also in now um
[Music]
in these positions if the pawn is not
on the rook's rank so
just being with the king in front of the
pawn
on the sixth rank is a win so
king f6 and black resigned
since after king of eight just
e7 and white is queening
so promoting so
taking the bishop was a mistake because
the the ending was completely lost for
white after
uh for black afterwards there are
many there are several solutions to this
the position is a draw here
uh bishop before was uh was a good move
white has no way to improve the position
or even
king f7 is is also a draw so black has
to
black had to prevent this rook h8
and now king f6 even king g6
or if king a5
now you see this uh bishop g7 is
is very possible rook g7
king f8 and because the white king is so
far away
white is going to to lose a pawn here
for example rook g6 trying to keep the
pawn
king of seven look f6 king e7
and yeah followed by rook h5 rookie five
uh white is simply not in time the king
had to be here in order to defend the e5
pawn
but the king is not in time so
black just takes this pawn and it's a
draw
so going back to it poison bishop
don't take it if black can win
no no the position is a draw i think
maybe white could slightly be pushing
but objective
objectively the position is a draw but
after bishop g7
black is completely lost so
let's move on to the next one
we have an interesting
position and my question is so in this
position solo versus short is the game
black plate knight d5
and my question is what do you think
about this move is it a good move or is
it a bad move or is just
a normal move
obviously white white white has some
pressure on the
e file and with this mode black is
simply
relieving the pressure on the e file
it doesn't lose a pawn it's um
it's transposing to uh
to opponent and game
yeah the pieces are going to get off the
board that's uh
that's today's topic um
simplifying to opponent end game
but they can be tricky
stops look to f4 yeah well
anyway rook couldn't go to f4 anymore so
when pawn takes nine well
this is what what i'm saying that black
is not
like it's not losing a pawn here
well yeah 95 there is uh
there is rookie 4 knight f6 and now just
take take but black is
black is quite all right here
that was not the point the point was
different
yeah exactly exactly so in the game
the gay continued rook takes e8 just
general
exchanges rook takes uh
rook takes queen takes
knight takes d5
and of course after uh c takes e5 25
white is
upon up with a winning
queen ending but black has a
resource here queen e1 hidden one
[Music]
king g2 queen e4
check well the pawn is not falling
and queen f3
yeah and we're talking about
we we are actually talking about this
this ending
yeah it's a fourth sequence of moves
yeah queen of three
and now black played queen d5 um
pawn takes d5 uh is just bad because
queen takes e4 pawn takes and now
g4 is uh
is winning for white this this ending is
winning for y
um for example
king f8
king g3 g5
take stakes f4
white can black and take either way
well he's well advised to take like this
king f3 but now the
king
okay this this is winning because black
spawns are stuck while
white can can simply bring the king
so in the game black
of course saw this and he goes queen d5
quintet pontex and
we got such a symmetrical position
interesting one what do you think about
this ending now
why to move
interesting position i should say
white is closer to center
uh yeah white white is a bit white's
king is a bit
closer to the center but the position is
symmetrical
all right king of three king of three is
king of three is good white wants to get
to the
d5 pawn with the king because as you
well noticed white's king is
more active and it
it goes forward
and yeah white is going after the d5
pawn fast in the game black
played f6 if um
if g6 then it's a long and interesting
line
so g6 in order to to avoid h5
white can go king f4
black cannot really allow this to happen
and now white goes h5 anyway
while taking on h5 is just lost because
of king f5
king f7 and now b3
and uh white has
many tempers in reserve
and black is going to lose the
opposition here and
just lose the ending so there is no way
to take one h5
therefore black goes king f7
and now it's very important to
um
this a4 is very important to fight for
for the tempe here
with opposition and everything but it
seems that white is
uh white should be winning this
so for example a5
yeah b6 also loses to f3 so
there and the idea is to go g4
and again
white black cannot win a tempo on the
queen sides and
and uh then white's king will just
push to f5 and h6 for example
something like a6
let's say and now b4
and whatever black moves say b5
white can go a5 black has to go
here keeps the opposition for now but
then there is f4 and
you see he loses the opposition and this
is decisive
so not uh
not b6 therefore
[Music]
black can go a5
and now we have f3 well it's a long
it's a long line but but an interesting
one f3
king g7
pawn takes king takes
g4
and again if black goes backwards then
king f5
is going to win because white has the f4
move in
in reserve so a good attempt here is to
go
f5
and what do you do here with white
why to move
[Music]
hello hello there
be sweet white one
well i was very careful before preparing
this to to just
to just delete the results so that you
cannot see who
who really won the games
so yeah king king 5 is very strong here
very good k5
uh centralizing the the king but um
of course it has to be it has to be
calculated because it's a
quite long variation so one takes
pawn takes king
g5 now now it's a pawn race here
um king d5
king g4 and now yeah
a very strong move is here king e5
the king has to be here
and now let's let us not calculate but
instead just push the pawns because it's
the only way
yeah now the material is going to be
equalized
queen everybody
and what is white playing here
how to continue this worldwide
yeah queen g8 is winning
yeah queen g8 is just winning uh
white is going to exchange the coins and
then uh
then the game is over okay queen b7 is
also possible but
okay queen b7 but even king h1
it's an easy win queen b7 was probably
more precise
so yeah long line but very very
interesting
line in the game black played f6
and here white continued h5 just to fix
this spawns and
now he he found a way to go there to f5
if g6 then king f4 will transpose to the
previous line
h5 here for black
each one should also be
should also be losing
probably just
white can push either king f4 or play g4
and
and win this so
here black played f6
and now h5
king of seven king f4
uh kg6 this was the game
g4
a6
a4 uh well
again white has some tempi and reserve
here
so a5 b3
b6
and how do we proceed here
why to move
absolutely very good
if f5
okay now after f5
all right so yeah g5 obviously this one
this one i think it's a draw after
[ __ ] f6
but obviously white goes g5 and
[Music]
then the f5 pawn is falling and the
position is winning
so k7 was played then king f5
king f7 and again what decides in this
game is that
white has an extra move f4
uh the decisive tempo
g6 he played
kg7 and he will take back the deeper
k6 g6
f5 this is important and again we got uh
we got the pawn race
king f7
f6 h5
again where do we put a king
36 yeah it's important i guess
well kinky five kinky five is good
it's like it's like in the previous line
and now white is winning here
f7 h2 queen
h1 and now what do we do
queen g very good queen g8 is
is winning
because again king of three there is
queen d5
and king h3 there is queen h7 and taking
the queen and then
the ending is completely winning
queen f4 for style points well queen f4
there may be
king h5 and i don't know
is not
[Music]
yeah queen of four king h5 while you're
making yourself
more you're making the situation more
difficult
probably it's still winning but
it's not so obvious how you can
hear king here it's not so obvious how
you can exchange the quiz
anymore but queen g8 just
is just winning
yeah so you see position was about
equal here i would say black just had to
go some
somewhere else like knight g6 knight c8
instead he went for this
and uh this 95 and then
after the first sequence of moves
there are this ending that is just
is just lost okay
so i hope you'll get better decisions
into how to uh
evaluate this uh this opponent
games that can that you can
[Music]
simplify into and yeah
i hope this was a useful lesson for you
thank you thank you everybody for
watching and
have a nice day bye bye